we did one last version of the visual
effect shot so we could see a little
more butt crack and I think it
spoiler alert
so first of all you're kicking off phase
five
what is that what does that conversation
look like with Kevin feige what do you
guys talk about is there anything that
they're like hey you've got to do this
this and that I think one of the things
you know we started writing this script
and I think even shooting the movie
we may have even finished the movie
before it was determined that we were
kicking off phase five I think really
what it was was you know I screamed my
director's cut and the movie obviously
is much bigger than the first two
Ant-Man movies and that was one of the
things that Kevin and Steven Broussard
our producer discussed early on is let's
do something different for this third
one and introduce a major villain
Jonathan major I think just left off the
screen as as kind of conqueror and it
really felt like okay this is this is
pointing the way toward you know a a
whole new face for Marvel so that was
exciting obviously for us uh with
Ant-Man is the original idea I think was
you know we want to pay off some of the
stuff we said set up in the first two
movies
let's go down into the quantum realm
let's answer the question of what Jana
Van Dyne was doing down there for 30
years and it also occurred to us that
that would be a perfect venue uh to
introduce this new character I obviously
knew getting the conquer from the comic
books
one of the Mount Rushmore Marvel Comics
villains and we love the idea of this
you know on paper kind of lopsided
confrontation between Ant-Man and wasp
and Kang there was just tension in that
idea from the beginning was Kang always
a part of the movie or was that
something that you guys really yeah now
we want to build up to Kang Dynasty Kang
was always a part of the movie yeah I
mean because we really wanted to find a
villain in the MCU or in the comics
realm that really you know was gonna be
someone absolutely formidable for
framing and wants to go up against Kang
made sense just because you know as as
the MCU has been steering toward these
multiversal stories and in the comics
he's obviously a time traveler but it it
made sense to sort of adapt him for that
and it worked with what was going to go
on in Loki so very early on as they were
developing Loki and we were developing
this movie it just made sense he's so
good you're right when he says he just
like leaps off the page like he is just
you can tell how strong he is in some of
these battles I'm curious because there
were a lot of theories
um and even some that I had where I was
like I think someone in the ant family
is not gonna make it out of this movie
like I was very nervous about that was
that something that you guys ever talked
about listen as we were developing the
movie early on as with all the movies
everything is on the table from the
beginning
I mean there were there were drafts of
the first Ant-Man movie early on where
Hank Pym died in the first movie but you
know it's always something we wanted to
talk about as we got to it and I think
you know we certainly leave the audience
down a path at least in this movie that
hold on what's going to happen to Scott
Lang at the end of this movie uh we like
we like the idea of playing around with
that but we certainly never intended to
kill Scott Lang
um you know I would I would have to go
into Exile I wouldn't be able to you
know to kill off all right I mean you
could certainly kill off Paul Rudd but
um it just didn't make sense in terms of
the progression of this Trilogy of
movies
um it just did not make sense
um but there's always those discussions
about
you know who's going to be uh who's not
going to make it out alive who's not
going to make it to the end of the movie
God one of this is kind of off of
quantumania but one of my favorite
characters that you introduce
introduced and I'm wondering how you're
feeling that she's coming back for
Thunderbolts oh man I love it I you know
Hannah is fantastic and I loved her in
that role and I loved what we were doing
in that movie which is to sort of create
not a villain necessarily but an
antagonist who just um was the result of
this horrible accident and you know was
sort of pulled into services that
assassin but really
you know we gave her you know a sort of
redemption Arc and I love to see that
she's going to live uh to to fight in
one way or another uh another day I'm
I'm stoked about that oh that's awesome
so a lot of times when when you think of
a Trilogy I think it's like also my Star
Wars brain a little bit you're like oh
that's a Trilogy that is the completion
of this and I think Thor was the first
one I think to get a fourth film did you
always Envision Ant-Man as a Trilogy or
is do you feel like there's more films
to go there I mean I I confess
definitely like when we were in the
first movie we just want to make sure
the first movie worked right like I mean
but in the back of your brain we grew up
I was part of that generation that grew
up on the original Star Wars Trilogy and
the Back to the Future Trilogy and what
at the time was uh Indiana Jones Trilogy
so it made sense and I liked the idea
because it really did have this
three-act structure
um as we started developing this story
um particularly with the Scott Cassie
Dynamic you know she's six years old in
the first movie Nine in the second one
and now she's 18 because of the results
of you know what happened in endgame but
that felt good to us that felt like if
that relationship is sort of the
emotional spine to the anime movies and
they're about family it's sort of seeing
Cassie become a hero in her own right
she you know she's not a little girl
anymore she's a young woman and has her
own ideas about morality and idealism
and what being a hero for her generation
means as opposed to Scots so that felt
like a you know a strong Trilogy again I
think it's I think it's terrible to
assume you're gonna get another movie
right I wanted to make sure that if we
didn't get another movie this felt like
you know it told a story in three movies
I felt like there was a little bit of s
Wars
the quantum realm a little bit Yeah
listen it's me I love Star Wars you know
I love Star Wars but I but I think it's
also this idea of let's create something
new I mean listen working on Mandalorian
was a joy for me to actually get to work
in the Star Wars Universe this thing I
wanted to kind of pull from all of these
different things that inspired me as a
kid and as an adult you know
um Heavy Metal magazine and you know
science fiction paperback covers and
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
flashlight yeah yeah different things
and because we had to populate this
entire sort of Worlds within world's
idea and create all these different
Aesthetics for the the groups that made
up the Freedom Fighters and all the
people that they encounter and also to
sort of service
Janet Van dyne's Story what the hell was
she doing down there for 30 years and
finding out that she had a much richer
life down there in many ways than she
had up on Earth uh
yeah bills well we needed someone to
come in there who sort of represented
her past life and
this one really in a Trilogy that's
really about family that we explore the
secrets that family members keep from
each other and the fact that she had
some kind of relationship with this guy
down there also struck us as funny of
you know sitting Michael Douglas and
Bill Murray at a table and have these
two alpha males go at each other and
struck us as funny yeah
um we have to talk about Modoc also a
great comic relief in the movie but also
like one of those things where you know
we've seen Modoc and animation and it's
like this this character could never
cross over to live action like how on
Earth would it work and it works so well
I'm curious what that process was like
for you was that really really tough
were there different designs modak was
tricky and particularly the version of
Modoc we did which you know you've seen
the movie it hinges on sort of this
character having a prior relationship
with our heroes obviously with Hank who
was his mentor at one point and Scott
who was his rival and he's also the guy
who came into Cassie's bedroom when she
was six and tried to kill her it made
sense in terms of progressing these
characters
and then the couple of things that we
really wanted to do like again we played
around like can we put that sort of
beetle bowl cut on Corey stole and have
it make sense and at a certain point I
felt like well no this is a different
version we want to we want a quick read
that this is still Darren cross and the
other thing is you know a lot of times
in in animation they put Modoc in a
context where he's he's just sort of
silly or playing at it we wanted to
actually introduce him as the thing he
says he is in a mechanized organism
designed only for killing so we
introduce him you know just laying waste
to this Freedom Fighter Village before
we reveal who he is but that was a real
challenge for for all the uh obvious
reasons uh I I I love that you guys
leaned into it too with just like the
Ant-Man being like what the hell is this
thing yeah yeah well that was a fun like
he's modok is living in his own movie in
his head he is like the most memorable
villain of all time and in fact Scott's
forgotten about him Hank's forgot him
but they've all forgotten about him
until he shows up again but in in his
head he's the he's the big he's the main
villain in this movie oh I always see
modoc's book
well that was uh come on that was the
best that was the thing that we
conceived and it was in the movie for a
brief period was out of the movies like
well we gotta have the we gotta have the
butt back we we did one last version of
the visual effect shot so we could see a
little more butt crack and I think it
it helped it's not the butt cut thank
you we got the butt cut
um I want to dig into the post-credit
scenes a little bit um did you direct
both of those and how do you decide
yeah
I directed the first one which was we
knew we wanted to sort of just give a
tiny Taste of the potential of what some
of these variants these Kang variants
are and brief nods to Rama Tut Centurion
the mortise maybe not the prime versions
maybe they're variants of those versions
but just to sort of let Jonathan run and
have some fun but always my idea was
let's let's end this thing with that
classic panel of the Council of kings
and do our version of that with all
these different Jonathan's so that
became its own sort of separate shoot
much like the shoot we did with Paul
earlier in the movie where they're
multiple Paws it's a technical nightmare
to do those sequences and it only works
if you have actors like Paul and
Jonathan who can really you know get
specific with those each of those
individual characters in their responses
and so that was fun the second one the
the uh the final tag
is actually a cut down version of a
scene from season two of logi
hi
spoiler alert
so you know that's obviously Victor
timely another Kang variant and and I
just I love the I love I I was went by
the set when they were shooting that and
I just I loved his Frederick Douglass
hair and his whole sort of uh the period
uh intonation of his voice and
everything so it really was to sort of
tease the audience with the idea of like
in Phase five
you're going to meet a lot of different
variants
it'd be interesting because at the time
of recording us the movie's not out yet
I I think I'll I don't know if anyone is
going to realize that the Kang that
we're getting in this movie is going to
die like this is not yes you know I
think one of the things we wanted to do
and again as you set out to do these
movies you TR you don't want to repeat
what's been done before and you want to
just try and catch the audience off
guard for good or for bad surprise them
and show them something different and
and and unexpected and uh you know I
think that we we do that throughout the
movie
and which ones they were gonna be we
talked a lot about it about who we
wanted to tease and sort of um
you know as they are as Jeff loveness
who wrote this movie is is uh starting
to write uh or is now well into writing
uh Kang Dynasty you know what we wanted
to sort of tease the audience with and
not get too definitive was like okay
here's the one who's going to be in this
thing or whatever but just sort of to
tease the thing
we knew weirdly like Rama Tut you know
just this sort of ancient Egyptian
version in the comics was something that
had potential but then we we sort of
vented a little bit it made him this
very strange sort of bionic variant of
ramadat but we wanted to give
three distinct feelings and set up the
idea of
this triumphant inside this sort of Star
Chamber and
now that Kang the Conqueror has met the
Fate he meets at the end of this movie
what does it mean for the larger
sort of political body of kangs right
um what happens in the sort of Godfather
type thing of this power struggle of
well why was he you know in the movie we
revealed that he was exiled into the
quantum realm and why and who who did it
but sort of starting to get into sort of
the political aspect of how the kangs
relate to each other
um which I think holds really strong
potential for phase five yeah definitely
my first stop I was like oh like that's
how you can get Moon Knight back in I
don't know
um
well Peyton thank you so much for your
time uh have there been any uh any
movement on to bring it on sequel or
what
ah I was hoping Ashley was gonna be your
uh your patented Bring It On question
um there have been you know again
Kirsten and I talked periodically and
Gabrielle and I've been spending a lot
of time with Jessica you know this book
uh just came out about the making of
Bring It On that case Wickman wrote and
just did an amazing job about that whole
process so we've been talking about how
we're going to structure it and do it so
um we're uh we're we're there's some
forward momentum we love to hear it do
your cheers Ash
birth
in here us that there must be
there we go
cheerleaders into quantumania but we
just didn't have room I love it well
thank you so much for your time
wonderful to see you as always I'll see
you on Twitter
[Music]